find the perimeter of this hexagon so
the perimeter just means the distance
around the object or if you add up all
of the lengths of the sides of the
objects we're going to add up all of the
lengths of sides of this hexagon and
hexagon is just a six-sided geometrical
shape like this so to find the perimeter
we just need to find the distance around
the hexagon which is going to be the sum
of all of the lengths of the sides so
the perimeter is going to be 24. so how
many of these do we have we have 1 2 3
four five six twenty fours which makes
sense because a hexagon has six sides so
we're gonna have 24 let me write this a
little bit bigger 24
plus let me write it like this
plus 24 plus 24
plus 24
plus 24
and let's see that's five 24's and we
have plus 24. so let's add them all at
the same time we could have done it
piece by piece but let's just go
straight ahead so let's go first at the
ones place so four plus four
four plus four is eight eight plus four
is twelve twelve plus four is sixteen
sixteen plus 4 is 20 20 plus 4 is 24
is 24
and now we're in the tens place 2 plus 2
is 4
plus 2 is six
plus two is eight
plus two is ten
plus two is twelve
plus two is fourteen plus two is
fourteen
so the sum of these six twenty fours is
144 that is the perimeter and when we
learn multiplication if you haven't
learned it already you could have done
this simpler you say you have 6 24 so
this would actually be a multiplication
problem of 6 times 24. if you don't know
how to do that just yet don't worry
about it you can just add them all up
you get 144.